the kiyose is listening a lot of people
come with a set of questions and then
they can't get off that set of questions
if they hear something new that you
could follow a tangent that might give
you something and I think the most
poignant time occurs when you're talking
to someone who experienced war because
that's life at paradoxically at its
height when your life is most threatened
when violent death is possible at any
second life is vivified lived at a level
we don't experience even insects or in
love or and anything that our normal
life delivers and so war is that one of
those paradoxical human experiences that
delivers us a sense of life lived at its
top and so that's what we're trying to
get out of people that we interview
about wars and I remember in our film
about the Second World War called the
war I asked a gentleman who was sort of
holding me at arm's length
understandably because of his experience
has been so bad I suddenly said to this
person who was no longer 85 or 86 years
old but back to being 19 years old I
just said I didn't even ask a question I
just said you saw bad things and all of
a sudden the lips started to quiver and
the cheek twitched and he began to tell
me not the sort of practiced defended
view of the war but something much more
complicated something that revealed its
horror he had watched men died he had
killed men he had seen it firsthand and
suddenly it was like passing through
some door some portal into his life and
his experience that I feel privileged
but only because I watched the potential
emerging of a 19 year old soldier in
France in 1944 in 1945 suddenly willing
perhaps for the first time to share some
of that horrible gruesome thing that we
need to know about if we're going to
know anything about the human condition
you